boire du coca soigne-t-il vraiment la
gastro on l'a tous cru enfant nausées
vomissement diarrhée prends un coca et
ça ira mieux après tout on s'en sert
pour dissoudre la crasse sur les pièces
de monnaie c'est grâce à l'acide
citrique dans notre corps sa combat les
infections le secret du coca c'est sa
caféine 40 mg par canette qui soulage
l'intestin et réduit les nausées par
contre le café ça marche pas il a plein
de molécules qui empirent la gastro non
buvez pas le coca c'est aussi du sucre
qui nous donne des calories et donc de
l'énergie mais ça ne marche pas avec le
like et le zéro et les bulles ça aide à
digérer non idée reçue le gazeuse est
riche en bicarbonate qui aide le transit
mais le coca non là les bulles attaquent
l'estomac et te font vomir le coca
manque aussi beaucoup de sels minéraux
si on boit pas d'eau on finit déshydraté
par la gastro plutôt qu'un soda buvite
du jus de citron avec du miel et un
bouillon de légumes salés voilà le vrai
remède ne croyez plus que